so that makes two wonderful evenings of
conversation in one evening at how many
people were able to park without
difficulty coming here tonight and how
many committed a violation in the way
they parked let's start with questions
for Donald who i think has some very
clear and challenging preachments for
the way we manage pavement and cars in
many places including Yale and New Haven
and the state of Connecticut sir now
let's more how we can get rid of on-site
parking requirements this is complicated
well well I was I was thinking is I
listen to Tom he seemed to be one of the
themes of what he said was the driving
seems simple but it's very complicated
and my view is that parking seems
complicated but it's very simple and it
would be much simpler if there were no
off-street parking requirements and I
think one of the reasons I think that it
can happen is that some cities have
already done it and the comparison I'd
like to make is between San Francisco
and Los Angeles the sum of you apart of
Disney Hall the new concert hall by
Frank Gehry in Los Angeles Los Angeles
requires as a minimum 50 times more
parking than San Francisco allows us the
maximum that in Los Angeles we have a
minimum with no maximum in San Francisco
has a maximum with no minimum now if
this were real science wouldn't you ask
what's going on
if one if in one city for the treatment
of tuberculosis was blood transfusion
and the other city it was bloodletting
wouldn't any scientists say that there
has to be some mistake here but we have
most of the cities that you really want
to go to like boston and new york and
chicago and san francisco and london and
paris and copenhagen they all have
maximum with no minimum the cities that
you don't want to go to by phoenix in
houston of Los Angeles they have
minimums with no maximum though I think
you have to decide what kind of city
want to be more like and I think that
we've had a long history of trying to
force up the parking supply and not
allowing anything that doesn't have what
we say is the minimum needed and I think
you could just point to cities that you
would rather go to I think one of the
cities that I really like is that is one
of the best places on earth for
pedestrians is Carmel California that
doesn't allow any off street parking in
its central business district they don't
want any cars driving across sidewalks
they bought all the interior space used
for shops and art galleries they think
that there's more to be gained for the
city now ppl park at the periphery and
market as one of the best places on
earth to be a pedestrian but hey I'm not
saying it's easy to do but I think that
or like I believe of the Alice in
Wonderland once you say something three
times that is true and I just have to
keep saying it over and over and I think
more cities are trying it other
questions done I'm sure there's been a
few municipalities mainly in the West
that that have changed their parking
policies and your book came and I'm
wondering whether there is much
opposition point if you either it chases
customers away from business areas or
that it costs too much for people who
you know every modest means well well
naturally I I hear that question a lot I
become I hope practiced in answering it
is that because I do have a second life
of Norwich of cities of giving my spiel
and there's always somebody who gets up
and it isn't a question a tentative they
say I'll never come back to downtown
Santa Rosa if you run the parking meters
after 6pm something like that and the
argument I would make to the merchants
and the property owners are they seemed
very receptive is that who do you think
will spend more in a store or leave a
better tip at a restaurant somebody who
will come only if they can park free
after they drive around long enough to
find a space or somebody who's willing
to park to pay for parking if they can
easily find the space which will make
the area more prosperous a the Old
Pasadena and when they put in parking
meters the merchants up good you know
drive everybody away but once the city
told the merchants of property or you'll
get the revenue like that face it that's
different let's run the meters till
midnight that's what I'm on Sunday it's
what you do with the money that is is
very key and then if I really don't like
the person who asked the question I said
and if you aren't willing to pay for
parking downtown maybe you'll find
you'll get a better deal in the food
court at a suburban mall with ample free
parking so everybody will win let's get
a question out of the front two roads
well we fill in the front row here we go
umm Danah I'd like to ask you what what
your opinion is about a parking supply
at rail stations and how you would
address the supposed demand issue there
and the local case may be illustrative
well you could probably predict what i'm
going to say and that is to charge the
right price for parking is that if all
the spaces are full the price should go
up and they're doing this in the San
Francisco area that they the BART system
was bay area rapid transit system was
supposed to lead to wonderful
development around the stations but
instead they were just parking lots they
were they were overflowing with cars I
take there's something different that I
would say as well as a not only charging
the bright price of the impartial clause
but I would say that I haven't seen this
happen really is that if their permit
parking districts around the around the
station so that you have to you can't
park on the curb on the street without
paying for it that you should allow the
commuters to pay for parking by the day
that they would have to pay to park on
the street and you would set the price
so that they're only three or four
commuter cars on every block and spend
that money to improve the the
neighborhood so that the Parkers and the
resins will be sore more symbiotic that
they that the people who want to drive
to the train station will be paying
guests they won't be freeloaders anymore
they'll be paying gas and that's that's
that's very different many universities
do that many but some like the
university of colorado at boulder which
does everything it right it seems in
environmental things but they in all the
surrounding neighborhoods they had two
surveys to see if there are some empty
spaces during the day because almost
everybody has to go work during the day
time to make it living to pay the
mortgages in Boulder so that if there's
less than seventy-five percent of
occupancy they'll sell up to for
non-resident per day time permits to
outsiders they charge them every month
what the residents have to pay for a
year the end of monday is used to reduce
the cost of the permits for the
residents so i think we have some of
those valuable land on earth now being
given away free to cars and the more you
can figure out a way
to make that land pay for public
services the better off we'll be in the
back as I understand that if we start
charging higher prices for parking in
the business district will this call
some ppl park of the nearby
neighborhoods well most cities would
would give the residence of permit to
park at the meter without paying you
know that the residents usually get
preference and Eddie in any district is
they have to to be bought off so I think
to make it politically popular everybody
who has a say the rez does the merchants
of the property or they all have to be
satisfied I think that the way to
southside the residence is to give them
permit parking and that if these permit
parking districts if there are some
vacant spaces you should sell the excess
to outsiders and use the money to
improve the the neighborhood and this is
beginning to happen in cities the thing
here is some valuable land let's make
use of it so the qosmio the employees in
stores can park there during the day and
they'll pay for it or their employer
will pay for it I let's pursue that a
little further done let's suppose we the
city always in need of cash looks at all
the metered space or meter a bold space
on its streets and says let's have an
auction investors from everywhere
hedge funds investment banks whomsoever
we're going to sell all these street
parking spaces and you can price it any
way you want would we be prepared to
make that leap I wouldn't recommend it
Chicago did do it the reason that they
gave was that they had they did not have
the political will to charge the market
rate prices for curb parking and they
outsourced the need for political will
to Morgan Stanley who paid over a
billion dollars for the the meter
revenue for 75 years and it's a perfect
example I'm sure what happened in any
city that they said we will put this
money into a lockbox it'll provide you
know revenue for schools or whatever for
the next 75 years within two years all
the money was gone it's what we're doing
everywhere is selling off assets to pay
for current expenses that's a bad idea
for a household it's a bad idea for a
city if the city cannot get its act
together and it manages parking properly
maybe it should lease it to a private
operator maybe it should have a
revenue-sharing agreement that they
split the revenue or something like that
but i think it's only for city says it
can't do it that it doesn't have the
capacity to do it then it should look to
the outside operators but they can be
brought in as partners rather than
selling it all we're going to turn to
top Vanderbilt in just a second but I
thought it might be sure Donna in the
slide ahead from a Purdue University one
thing I forgot to mention was that
pigeon house key found that interesting
he despite this despite this abundance
of parking he found that people he
surveyed still found that there was not
enough parking and I don't know if this
is necessarily a peak demand issue or
about leads the question about sort of a
psychological the perception of what is
available parking and how that sort of
plays swimming
if this has been studied in to an extent
and yes it has it parking is so much
simpler than driving that it's been
studied very well but whenever there
soon a place like West Hollywood is a
hot spit spot of Los Angeles now very
trendy people say there's a terrible
shortage of park including off street
parking we need more of it and I went
into the parking garage as you take
pictures of the ground floor spaces and
they're just covered with oil spots you
go up to the top deck and it looks as
though there has never been a car on it
that is pristine white concrete is zone
there never been an oil spot I went to
the top of the temple street garage I
did not see a single oil spot on it I
think that that the spaces that you can
see are the first base is to be taken
and it looks as though they're there
there's a shorter but when you go to the
space and people can see there are a lot
of them but getting back to buy one load
I would say the first spaces you see are
the curved spaces and if they're all
full you think there's no parking and if
we got the price right for curb parking
nobody could say there's a shortage of
parking because everywhere they went
they would see one or two vacant spaces
on every buck they could never say
there's a shortage because it well some
people what I suppose but but most
people would this is really potent and
interesting stuff and a persuasive to me
and they're ultimately there's a
distributive side of this where I mean
lot of people with highly duparc and low
incomes are going to get squeezed by the
market mechanism in this case as in any
other are we prepared to override that
consideration Donald well I think I have
a good answer for that as well because
it's obviously the first thing that
people say and I think I'm not accusing
you of second but the people who don't
want to pay for parking they push poor
people out in front of
like human shields take don't charge for
parking it'll hurt poor people when they
really mean don't charge for her parking
because it will hurt me and I would say
that some of the people who would
benefit most are the the poorest part of
any population New Haven has lots of
poor people they could benefit from
higher public revenues the buses would
run faster because the there wouldn't be
so many cars driving around hunting for
a free car parking space and and slowing
down the buses that's one of the main
reasons that San Francisco is doing it
they justify it will help poor people
more than anybody else really poor
people okay we've got a little time left
and another fascinating argument let's
see we can do with questions directed to
Tom Vanderbilt thank you I want to take
advantage of the fact that Tom
Vanderbilt is a journalist and there are
other journalists in the crowd I've been
on a personal tear for some time about
the way we refer to transit as public
transit or mass transit or public
transportation or mass transportation
nothing are hardly ever does a good
thing come after the word mass or after
the word public so think a murder and
toilets for example as journalists I
would love to beg you to only ever refer
to transit as transit ever again thank
you good editorial acknowledged
questions out there yes a back right kit
you're gonna have to bail it out
that would be a more hopeful sign and
often you know kids these days aren't
really playing around those signs
because they're inside on their
Nintendo's or whatever but yeah I mean
school zones are a strange thing to me
there's been some studies that actually
stop people after they during this
school zone they've tracked them on
radar on a how fast they were going then
ask them how fast were you going they're
off by 10 miles an hour and this is what
I have a problem with certain in Texas
for example this new legislation which
bans you can how does it work in Texas
it now bands and held cell phone use in
school zone areas but it's okay to use
your handheld cell phone everywhere else
so this this sort of assumes that number
one you've seen the sign number two
you're actually going to stalk or
conversation right at the moment you
enter this so and it begs the question
of are you asking people to drive in one
manner here and then act less safely in
other areas so and clearly there's a
reason we need some schools amplified
school zone protection because of the
habits of children but yeah I mean this
is the argument to get back to the
question about seeing things there's so
much more potent than actually seeing a
sign advising of them and the famous
argument here is Bryan Arthur's safety
and I'm I'm liking on the name excuse me
the safety in numbers argument which is
basically that the more you see of
something the more likely you are to
actually see that thing which has been
advanced to help explain why countries
like the netherlands and denmark in
addition to having better facilities to
begin with have one such lower vestrion
and cyclist fatality and injury rates
that the guy wrists are so accustomed to
dealing with them to seeing them and and
it's sort of a nice cycle the more
pedestrians you see sort of drive slower
and you see the pedestrians for a longer
time and it also works in back loops oh
yeah
Tom I share your affinity for incentive
based programs and for bears approach
book nudge and stuff like that I'm just
curious if you've come across any
incentive based programs that you've
seen that are actually working to impact
certain traffic patterns or negative
traffic behavior that we've seen in the
past well I mean the obvious thing here
would be congestion pricing which is a
disincentive of course but trying to
think of some other time een the sum of
the stuff in the u.s. I've seen has only
been sort of hypothetical giving people
for example of a program called what
does the choices done in this Puget
Sound Seattle area which gave people
sort of an account an imaginary account
of money that they could based on the
amount of miles they drove and an end of
the month they would be given some of
that money back based on if they drove
at a different time off peak or if they
just drove less in general and that
program had you know pretty robust
results people wanted money back and I
mean that's sort of just hypothetical
and it was sort of a congestion pricing
lead in that never went anywhere but I
you've got me for other just a quick
thing I'm not saying the California does
anything right but one thing that I
would recommend is called parking cash
out is that many employers give their
employees free parking and in California
that if you have over 50 employees if
you rent the parking spaces to give your
employees you have to offer the
employees the option to take the cash
value of the parking if they don't take
the partner there's not charging them
for parking it just makes them aware
they have an alternative they'd rather
ride the bus ride transit or if they'd
rather bicycle or a walk or carpool they
could have the cash value of the parking
subjects the employer can't say i will
give you free parking or nothing which
is what almost every employer in the
united states does i think we have time
for one or two concluding questions yes
l
yeah good observations I mean on the
first one I'm it's not a new observation
that you know people feel insulated from
the environment around them as they
drive a car but in with regard to the
windows being up this is something we're
even cabin noise has been studied and in
the absence of have annoys people
actually measurably drive faster noise
than one of these feedback systems when
drive a small convertible or something
much more where I am and we're driving
around it's very large insulated who's
fence relationship the neighborhood
around you and um just on the second
comment reminds me of I think safe
routes to school did a study looking at
traffic injuries for children around
schools and found them that majority of
kids were injured by other parents
taking their kids to that same school so
and this is something you know again
comparing the early 70s to now and I was
young I broken the suburbs yet I like
the Bradys I walked to school this was
not a bizarre behavior when the fifty
percent of American kids did that only
three decades ago now it's down to about
sixteen percent and you know last
question George a glitch in the fan I
guess it's got to be really loud tour
yeah
parking places far forward for this
plane 30 but with a city yeah I was the
arrangement to which the speaker refers
is that the city in 1991 least High
Street and Wall Street to Yale for 99
years and the the the object was to put
cash in the city and give the university
planning control over its interior
streets and George the III guess your
objection is that what what goes into
the meters does go to the city but the
planning control is with Yale and I
believe that you're a long-standing
opponent of that arrangement
ok we have a distinguished member of the
audience here from Connecticut do tea
and he's got a laugh not so much a
question is a really knob servation I'm
drummer with the Connecticut t OT and
yes we are going to expand parking
capacity here in New Haven as part of a
larger vision for transit oriented
development around the station and given
the current state of revenues here in
Connecticut we are going to charge
market rate for that private parking I
can assure you of all all of that you
mentioned Phoenix earlier today very
good observation they actually recently
built a light rail system in Phoenix
connecting Mesa through Tempe into
downtown Phoenix expected 17,000 riders
per day I worked on the system I
actually oversaw the opening the system
I'm sorry and the the ridership on that
system despite free ample parking in
downtown is 40,000 people per day the
system just opened up in december two
thousand eight so as long as there's a
good alternative it's a parking downtown
and that maybe public transportation
pardon me Holly but there's there's ways
in which we can achieve this and lastest
this did behavior that you talked about
on writers I I wish I had been able to
sort of document this over time and I
hope my wife is not seeing this by any
chance but she we've grew up in Boston
she didn't get a driver's license till
she was 32 years old because we moved
from Boston we actually had started
driving cars and she went from being a
raving lunatic and in and quite honestly
I'm really hoping she's not watching
this she's a lawyer very bad for me but
her behavior since we moved back to a
more transit friendly Connecticut is
much better and she's in a much better
mood for all that so thanks and let's
have a round of applause for these
wonderful
you